Hi, I'm Miranda Kerr...
...and I'm so excited to be the newest face and hair of Clear Scalp and Hair here in the US.
Today, we're here in New York City...
...and we're filming the new television commercial for Clear Scalp and Hair.
The ad is all about building resilience from the foundation,...
...for hair that feels strong and unbreakable.
Resilient hair is the hair that can handle all kinds of daily torture,...
...that I know about between photo shoots, and runway shows and events,...
...I have put my hair through a lot of torture.
And I must say that using Clear products has really helped my hair be more resilient...
...so it can bounce back and come out looking gorgeous.
I really love Clear's total hair collection.
It's like a one-stop shop for your hair.
The range is great for dryness, for flyaways, for frizziness, or for damaged hair.
So it's my go-to shampoo for every day.